donald trump was censored earlier today
and
uh many people on the left said he
wasn't actually censored they said
his tweet is still available therefore
it's not censored but it was
when you would so trump had two tweets
one of those tweets said that the
military was assigned he essentially
said the military was standing by
and that if you know when the looting
starts the shooting starts
there were two tweets the second tweet
was made unavailable
by twitter meaning if you went to the
first tweet you could not see the second
it just said this tweet is unavailable
that's censorship just because you can
still find ways to figure out through it
that's just called navigating the
censorship so
if you went to trump's actual twitter
account you'd see a box that said
this tweet has broken the rules for
glorifying violence well as it turns out
the white house has tweeted an email
they received from twitter saying
nope you didn't break any rules and i
think i have it i don't know exactly
which uh which tweet it is so let me try
and figure it out
so here we go right here twitter and an
email to the white house moments ago
admitted that the very tweet they are
censoring does not violate any twitter
rules so why are they still censoring it
and we can show you both examples here
this is an email they are posting
that mentions the the email that was
censored these thugs are dishonoring the
memory of george floyd and i won't let
that happen
just spoke to governor tim walls and
told him that the military is with him
all the way
any difficult difficulty and we will
assume control but when the looting
starts
the shooting starts thank you they said
we have investigated the reported
content and could not identify any
violations of the twitter rules
now look look at this right here this
tweet
violated the twitter rules about
glorifying violence however
twitter has determined that it may be in
the public's interest for the tweet to
remain accessible
so this is hidden if i click it
you can see the original tweet so yes
there are varying degrees of censorship
but as i mentioned they made it
unavailable mark zuckerberg
issued a statement which is wow
now he starts his statement with this
you know what looks like
pr pandering where he talks about you
know amit arboree brianna taylor and i
can respect it because i'm not happy
those people lost their lives for sure
but it's really much like please don't
get mad at me
i get it we're dealing with tough times
he says uh
another conversation happening amongst
our black friends colleagues and
neighbors are incredibly painful
as americans this affects all of us and
we have an obligation to help address
the inequality
in how justice is served this is
becoming something i care deeply about
that's where it gets interesting he says
i've been struggling with how to respond
to the president's tweets and posts all
day
personally i have a visceral negative
reaction to this kind of divisive and
and inflammatory rhetoric this moment
calls for unity and calmness
and we need empathy for the people and
communities who are hurting
we need to come together as a country to
pursue justice and break the cycle
but i'm responsible for reacting not
just in my personal capacity
but as the leader of an institution
committed to free expression
i know many people are upset that we've
let the we've left the president's posts
up
but our position is that we should
enable as much expression as possible
unless it will cause imminent risk of
specific harms or dangers
spelled out in clear policies we looked
very closely at the post
that discussed the protests in minnesota
to evaluate whether it violated our
policies
although the post had a troubling
historical reference we decided to leave
it up
because the national guard references
meant we read it as a warning about
state
action and we think people need to know
if the government is planning to deploy
force our policy around incitement of
violence allows discussion around state
use of force
although i think today's situation
raises important questions about
what potential limits of that discussion
should be the president later posted
again saying the original post was
was warning about the possibility that
looting could lead to violence
we decided that this uh that this post
which explicitly discouraged violence
also does not violate our policies
and is important for people to see
unlike twitter we do not have a policy
of putting a warning in front of posts
that may incite violence
because we believe that if a post
incites violence it should be removed
regardless of whether it is newsworthy
even if it comes from a politician
we have been in touch with the white
house today to explain the positives as
well
and then he closes out talking about
heated debates but man will i tell you
what
wow he is absolutely right on that issue
i'm i'm
i'm impressed with mark zuckerberg today
guys i agree um i mean
i want to go back real quick and just
point out you know some of the things
he's saying that
he's basically calling out twitter for
saying they think the post is newsworthy
i think it's that's a sharp dig at
twitter twitter didn't say news where he
said public interest
yeah but mark zuckerberg clearly thinks
that they leave things up because of
news potential
but wow is it amazing mark zuckerberg is
actually correct
okay yeah trump was warning about
looting and trump tweeted this here's
what he said
looting leads to shooting and that's why
a man was shot and killed in minneapolis
on wednesday night
or look at what just happened in
louisville with seven people shot
i don't want this to happen and that's
what the expression put out last night
means
it was spoken as a fact not as a
statement it was very it's very simple
nobody should have any problems with
this other than the haters and those
looking to cause trouble on social media
honor the memory of george floyd and of
course you can always expect jennifer
rubin to time in with her stupid reply
guy post what a pathetic lie i don't
care please just stop
he's explaining himself he is explaining
himself and uh
all these people out there are not
honoring george absolutely
not no i know that that is huge right
there we need to honor him
and and yes he needs justice absolutely
like andy this guy and he's getting it
yeah exactly it's not about george floyd
anymore
it's it's not it's it's a much bigger
thing they're chanting in houston what
um
charges aren't enough is that what
they're saying so what's what's enough
change the entire nothing's societal no
it'll it'll get down
like wait they're throwing bricks at
cnn's windows right
what does that do with george floyd
nothing what is riding in atlanta
and burning you know cars and stuff have
to do with george floyd in
minneapolis okay okay i can i can
entertain this and say
it's the greater injustice of police
brutality across the country right
and systemic violence and all that stuff
but wouldn't you then
protest the police exactly why are you
going to cnn
why are you going to target why didn't
they go to fox news why are you going to
autozone
why are you going autozone why are you
why are you burning down wednesday
wendy's yeah low-income housing
right yeah yeah well i i think we know
we can we can certainly talk about that
but this the censorship issue i think is
really important right now
and we are in a really crazy time so uh
i mentioned this earlier i
i you know periodically will dm with
jack and uh
we had a conversation uh the gist of it
is
we need open source public access
networks
and i'm kind of i i i like jack dorsey
uh the conversation i had with him you
know last year with joe rogan
you know off-camera afterwards i really
do think
he is a good person who wants to do
right who is incredibly
incredibly naive i mean we we spoke
about this before and you also alluded
to the fact that he
he doesn't run twitter anymore right
well that's my opinion oh okay okay
my opinion is that he's more of a
figurehead right vagina that's what i
was saying
that's why she showed up the jurgen
podcast because the issue about twitter
was what boiled over and he needed her
to talk about it
when uh so right now yeah so right now
ted cruz wants a criminal investigation
of twitter
for violating the the iranian sanctions
twitter allows the ayatollah and
high-ranking officials at some
these countries they allow them access
to the platform which provides a service
for them displaying their message to all
of these people
and that according to several
republicans including ted cruz is a
violation of these
uh of sanctions yeah vegeta is the one
who wrote the letter saying
too bad yeah it was it was amazing this
was back in february
and she basically said we provide a very
important public service for people to
connect with you know world leaders and
stuff like that
and my reaction is like and so
so i i i i look directly against the law
right
what if you said i understand you're
upset about the sanctions on this
country but we provide a very important
service in self-defense that's why we're
supplying weapons
you know i understand it's not a one for
one yet giving weapons to an enemy is
different
but they're allowing them to
propagandize in our country against us
when their adversaries and their
gunships are swarming ours and you know
people are
they're shooting at each other like
warning shots and stuff and at the same
time censoring the president
yup of our country yeah that's part of
what
trump's executive order was that they
allow
chinese disinformation on the platform
but sent to the president
so then twitter immediately reacts and
puts a flag on the chinese
communist party's tweets misinformation
and that's when i was like oh they're
sweating bullets
yeah i i'm look you know i have good
things say about jack as a person
i say he's naive because i think he kind
of understands
network technology but he has no
understanding of like contemporary
politics
at all yeah and so this is the problem
we're facing with these big tech
companies
there it's it's it's young people who
have
found this powerful technology that is
damaging political discourse across this
country
making things worse they have no idea
how politics works they have no idea the
intricacies of certain issues
they have no idea how the media lies and
the problems of solving these these
issues
and then they drop nuclear bombs sensor
so here's the first the craziest thing
i'm i'm impressed mark zuckerberg i got
to say it too
i've ragged on that guy a lot it's the
first time i've ever heard nuts but that
was never
that was like yeah that was that was a
great post
so donald trump tweeted about if mail-in
voting is allowed there will
there's no way there won't be widespread
voter fraud jack
twitter put a tag on this saying get the
full fax
when you click it it brought you to the
opinion columns of certain news
organizations and i was like
huh yeah where where are the facts you
want to know why
you want to i got really mad about this
why because uh
in paterson new jersey right now 3 000
ballots have been just have been avoided
yeah right and the signatures don't
match
the en double icp leader is calling for
the
election to be outright cancelled and
everyone agrees
this year's election the presidential
election no no no no no no no this is
this is
the election this is a local election oh
that was mail and vote only a local
election mail and vote only three
thousand
bunk ballots yeah some people said my
belt was disqualified but that was my
ballot why was it disqualified
so it's a it's a nightmare they say
there's no evidence of this
but the story is happening right now and
activists are
like we need to do something about this
and so i'm i'm like
why jack would you fact-check an opinion
so he basically apologized for this sort
of he
sort of apologized saying we shouldn't
have done that or something and we
should you know he put a statement about
how they're going to continue to
fact-check the president
but i my my response is there's no
circumstance
where you can just determine who is
correct
that so so this is why i think jack is
completely naive and so wrong about this
his assumption is cnn is is is his news
they're right
trump is the president but he's not new
so he's wrong so then when you get cnn
saying there's no mail-in voter fraud
and i live in a state where watching it
happen right now that i find that
offensive
yeah that you would you these people
especially
a marginalized group that you don't care
that's why it's all super
all the protest stuff is superficial you
don't actually care about the stuff you
read the news you believe what they say
and it's wrong
there will likely be widespread voter
fraud
the problem is calling it voter fraud
you should call it um
you know voter manipulation maybe no no
like incompetence
yeah okay so uh real quick real clear
politics did well it's worse than that
though
because the signatures didn't match so
it's manipulation though so it's a
little worse than the incompetent can we
that's like them losing the
the ballots instead of changing them
but that's that's delicious that's where
i was going okay real clear politics
said that in the past four elections
federally
28 million ballots have gone missing
that's insane 28 million
that's a lot of votes seven million
votes per election people
that's crazy yup and they want it
and then when trump says it an opinion
twitter intervenes
with more opinions imagine it this way
you know twitter is basically saying
that they want
their goal to be providing counterpoints
or something yeah
okay so uh i don't know climate change
is disputed
does that mean if al gore tweets climate
change is bad you're gonna put a tag
showing a bunch of people saying there's
such a thing as climate change is that
real does that mean when greta tunberg
says
you know we've got 12 years to make
changes you'll put a tag and you'll link
to a bunch of conservatives are going
no of course he's not going to do that
therein lies the big problem yeah
so what good to me matt is biased i we
we talked about this a year ago
federated networks look at this think of
this way
what is that it's it's a uh so jack did
a big twitter thread about this okay
and i want to see it happen in december
uh he tweet he tweeted about it in
december
i want to see it happen he said twitter
should basically be a protocol
what that means is like http
you type in a browser a web address you
go there and get it
okay the way this would work is the
reverse of
email so whereas email is i put in your
address
and the message gets sent to you twitter
should be
that i subscribe to your address and
whenever you post it goes to everyone
subscribed to your address
so if they if twitter opened up to the
the fetiverse
federated networking like which which
includes gab for instance
gab is you know alternative version of
twitter sort of then
you could go on twitter and when twitter
bans i don't know
you adam kriegler okay you set up your
own server on your own website
and then i go on twitter and search for
adam adamkrigler.com
and then i can click follow and then on
twitter i can still see your tweets
oh okay because you aren't on twitter's
network i'm just receiving your feed
so twitter is the biggest version of
this but they could all connect and then
no one could ban anyone
and then you know what i would do i'd
create my own i'd create my own
timcast.com
version of twitter yeah that only is for
me no one can ban me
and i can follow everybody and everyone
can follow me
it sounds legit yep so think about it
this way
let's say you're on twitter and you
follow
you know tim at you know uh
teamcast.irl.com or something i do
well no it's not i know a form of that
yeah
let's say twitter bans me and i say
we've disconnected irl
they've they're every other server i'm
still connected to
so you still get my feed and then you're
on twitter and you're like i can't get
tim anymore
i better open up a new account yeah on a
private server
so it incentivizes companies not to do
this
i i don't know man it's it's big it's
kind of like what bit shoot is isn't it
you know like people people have told
you all the time oh youtube took this
video away
and you're like oh and then they're like
don't worry i'm watching it on bitchu
well that's like a backup
system right okay it's similar i guess
the fetaverse would basically be like
you know technically you can get your
website banned like what happened with
um i think it was was it the daily
stormer
is the land of the website that is the
terrible website that we don't like
terrible
i don't like but they had a website and
google seized their domain name or
something like this yeah
yeah dude that's that's that's wow
that's not right
they like put a lock on it or something
and shut them down i get it man
they post nasty enough people don't like
but wow so it can still happen they can
sever the chain at a bunch of different
links yeah but if you're on your own
website you can someone can follow based
on your
web address yeah you can go to
teamguest.com no one's going to ban
timcast.com
it's like i own the domain and i pay for
hosting the host can can ban my server
time i can set up my own server
so you compared it to an rss feed well
no i don't know that's it's protocol
it's the easier way to explain it
okay yeah that made sense to me oh well
there's dope well i want to see it
that sounds awesome well here's here's
the issue soon or what
no i don't know i don't believe it it's
been it's been over a year
and like three months yeah since i sat
down with jack
and was like when are you going to fix
this and where are we now
no it's worse yeah it's worse than it's
ever been they're more dug in
and they're just making controversy
after controversy i heard their stock
dropped because of this
really oh good good well i mean think
about what tick tock did
because you know they're owned by that
chinese company or whatever when when
people started getting harassed
by bullies they banned the victims of
the harassment
yeah because it's easier to ban the one
person than the 300 doing the harass
you lose money if you give it to 300
people yeah it was
actually the smarter thing to do but
totally yeah totally savage
savagery yeah all right well true
i don't uh i don't i don't know man
twitter is
is totally broken and biased and it's
like they're desperate to please
everybody and you can't do it yeah
no they're desperate to please a certain
crowd not
everybody no they do want to please
everybody okay but they're biased in
what they read
sure okay otherwise they would just ban
trump out right they'd be like you got
it
gone yeah so here's my question what
makes these people at twitter
so arrogant they think they can change
the direction of the wind
you can't do it you are it's like it's
like watching someone stand in a river
and
try and push the river aside or push the
water back
yeah yeah they're like go back up go
back up or like they stop the water and
they're like we've done it we've dealt
with a problem and meanwhile
everything's flooding past them and
you're like you've done
nothing to stop anything just stop
getting in the way you're making it
worse
let people fact check trump they do
every day they tweeted them they say
nonsense
there you go trump should turn off for
well oh actually i wonder if trump can
turn off replies now this is
think about this oh i bet he can a court
ruling
trump can't block people because when he
tweets he creates a public forum
right and he's a government actor
twitter made a thing for verified users
where you can stop it so
so only um people you mention only the
people you follow or people you
mentioned
oh okay or or mention yeah okay so trump
could turn off replies
only for blue checks right oh wow trump
should do this
so many so many careers would be gone if
they're
they're trump reply guys yes who who
build the following and then and then do
a shout out like donate to my paypal
uh huh yep trump could get rid of all of
them right now
because when he tweets he can just say
only if i mention you can you respond
and then no one can
what do you mean he hasn't blocked
anyone he did he had to he was forced to
unblock them
in the instance where he says you can't
respond unless i have you oh right
right not blocking you exactly so it's
not it's not a violation of whatever
ruling or whatever
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you